enter the unnatural world of artist
oliver elias in' the fog tunnel is
called your blind passenger visitors
stumble through the 39 meters hands
outstretched eyes trying to register a
strobe light flashes on a fountain of
water the liquid morphs and breaks a
walk through kaleidoscope of mirrors and
colors the visitor becomes a participant
in the art misting rain makes an
ever-changing rainbow all perfect for
the instagram world underneath the fun
and the whimsy of the show lies a
serious message for decades elias and
has been highlighting climate change and
now the issue is more relevant and more
urgent than ever
icelandic glaciers photographed by the
artists in 1999 are now juxtaposed with
the same image taken this summer the
same glaciers the same angle the same
distance
there's no denying the masses of ice and
snow have receded significantly in just
20 years
Elias and is more conscious than most of
climate change but even he was shocked
once I saw the difference because I saw
the glazes in the 90s amazing and
they're kind of still amazing but when I
see the two next to each other you
realize there's something that was
invisible that became visible something
became explicit because you cannot
somehow see 20 years besides making
popular accessible art to raise
awareness of the climate emergency
Ellison provides practical solutions
he's invented a solar-powered lamp used
by more than a million people in
developing countries the light comes
from renewable energy that won't melt
glaciers and harm the natural world
Jessica Baldwin al-jazeera London